ist das geil also wenn ich jetzt einen
cousin hätte oder so dann kleinen sohn
den ich noch nicht habe dann würde ich
immer auf jeden fall so was als wecker
direkt kaufen ja leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich habe wirklich einiges
ach so ich weiß ich bin gerade und
schafft das regeln wir gleich noch auf
jeden fall habe ich einiges umgestellt
3 4 5 6 7 8
wir haben ja auf jeden fall acht pakete
mit über 25 sachen würde ich mal
schätzen und zwar kam er vor ungefähr
einer woche das video von mir amazonen
produkte mit einem stern also einer
schönen rezension viele haben gesagt
macht das doch bitte auch mit fünf
sternen ich habe mich hingesetzt hat
einige produkte rausgesucht und damit
starten leute in diesen paketen sind
jetzt nicht so die fünf sterne produkte
wir haben auch einige andere sachen wie
zum beispiel eine menge adventskalender
also dazu gibt es auf jeden fall in
dieser woche auch noch ein video wir
starten jetzt hier nicht erst mit dem 5
sterne produkten bevor wir die auspacken
würde ich sagen wir checken erstmal am
pc was habe ich so bestellt wie wird das
bewertet warum wurde es so bewertet
taugt das und wenn ihr bock habt auf dem
produkt davon
ich habe alles diesmal in der video
besteuerung verlinkt könnte aber einfach
auf den link klicken und euch das mal
genauer anschauen ja leute bevor wir
weiter machen und würde ich sagen wir
schauen uns erst mal ein bisschen die
produktdaten die ich bestellt habe also
wie schon eben gesagt es handelt sich
heute ausschließlich um 5 sterne
produkte also leute ich würde sagen
gefangen an mit diesem snappy insekten
finger er habe ich bestellt einfach weil
ich sehr oft hier in meinem zimmer
irgendwelche insekten rumfliegen habt
und die zu dumm sind man kann es halt
nie finden nicht so schnell wie haben
auf jeden fall fünf sternen hier 835
leute alter mittlerweile habe ich drei
davon im haus verteilt damit ich lieber
schnell eingeschnappt zur hand habe also
das schreiben leute wirklich nur
positive ist und ich bin auch froh jetzt
anscheinend einen zu besitzen als
nächstes habe ich diese lampe bestellt
ebenfalls ihr fünf sterne
ja das ist eine lampe die kann man schon
oft an acht stellen kann vermutlich in
verschiedenen farben leuchten ich habe
keinen plan ihr schaut man das sieht ja
echt
sehr angenehm aus ich sehe ja irgendwie
so brav aus finde ich nur na ja
stielicke lampe mit stimmungs licht
schon länger suchen einer kompakten und
schöne schreibtischlampe blablabla alle
sind hier wirklich begeistert ja was ich
eigentlich megageil fandel war dieser
wecker und zwar für kinder gibt es hier
ein lego ein exot und kinder weg haben
mit mini figur ja den habe ich auch
bestellt auch als ich den bestellt heute
der fünf stellen jetzt hat er nur noch
viereinhalb sorry perfekt um
erstklässler den einstieg zu erleichtern
alles klar vielleicht auch um einen uni
leben bis hin zu erleichtern dann komme
ich auch mal pünktlich demnächst wir
werden sehen wir haben noch einen schuh
diesen schuh habe ich nicht für 34 euro
gekauft dann habe ich für 20 euro oder
leute hier kann man es sehen für 20 euro
habe ich diesen schuh gekauft kostet
jetzt anscheinend 34 euro und ich habe
mir gedacht alter sohn schuh für 20 euro
den nehme ich mal mit ja auch fünf
sterne nur gutes steht hoffentlich ich
finde sie super bequem sie passen wie
erwartet also wird es haben sich euro
kann man sich nicht beschweren unbekannt
paul günther ja wieso ein flieger davon
hatte ich früher auch mal einen die
gehen wirklich richtig ab und den test
mal durch auch mal und zu guter letzt
ich weiß nicht vielleicht aber irgendwas
vergessen aber panini fifa world cup
sticker kollektion habe ich auch noch
mitgehen lassen
gut also soviel dazu wir packen jetzt
das ganze aus bin wirklich sehr gespannt
und vor allem bei dem schuh würde ich
sagen wenn ihr euch gefällt klickt
einfach mal auf den link in der video
beschreibung
ich habe das alles verlinkt dann kann
man sich jedes produkt hiervon auch halt
kaufen
herzlich willkommen zurück wir fangen an
mit dem auspacken ich bin wirklich sehr
gespannt das ist auch für mich war das
spannendste hier ist auf jeden fall
schonmal adventskalender in den brauchen
wir raten ich war ja das erste produkt
was wir hier haben ist dieser flieger
ich glaube der traum gefährt fünf euro
bekommst sie wurde auf jeden fall sehr
gut bewertet in deutschland hergestellt
ich hatte mir den um ehrlich zu sein ein
bisschen größer vorgestellt und auch so
ein bisschen robuster ist besser einmal
kurz wieder fliegt natürlich welcher
auch noch am besten testet leider immer
so ein bisschen nach oben ab muss man
mal draußen testen hier mal kurz in
aussicht so leute
erstmal checken
aber da ist schon ordentlich leute hier
haben wir auch schon das nächste paket
hier ist auch wieder einiges was genau
ist das was ist das war die 5 sterne
mystery box und ich habe es bei der
jugend wie du noch gesagt in jeder
perfekten mystery box ist eine
sonnenbrille warum diese andritz meinen
titel
das ding hat zehn euro gekostet ich
hab's doch im kopf wir haben hier eine
tüte wir haben noch eine tüte wir haben
noch eine tüte
das hier ist weiß ich nicht also hier
muss ich wirklich sagen zehn euro
absolut es sei denn jetzt gold drin und
was das hier sein soll weiß ich nicht
hier stehe ich hier leider ist kein
elektroschocker noch einmal kommt der
[Musik]
name ist also die box verlinkt ich euch
schon mal nicht in der beschreibung die
brauchte keiner von euch absoluter müll
dann machen wir einfach mal schnell hier
wird weiter
ich muss ja nicht sagen das ist auch
wirklich für mich ich fühle mich so ein
bisschen wie wir an weihnachten so leute
weitergeht ich habe absolut keine ahnung
was sie jetzt drin ist wo es diese
verpackung für das ich hatte nicht einen
pack dies ja bei der wm kenne ich nicht
kenne ich nicht wenn ich nicht ja geil
hat sie auf jeden fall gelohnt 90 cent
in die tonne leute waren weiter mit
folgenden paket das hier müssen jetzt
vom aussehen einfach mal ja ich würde
sagen die schule sein das ist ein
gegenstand den kann ich wirklich selbst
brauchen meine schuhe werden
rechtlich und denkt dran ich habe die
für 20 euro bekommen ich habe es euch
eben ja schon gesagt die haben wir einen
ganz klassischen schuhkarton von der
marke kappa ich finde der sich
eigentlich sogar extra aus und wenn man
den rauch macht das ganze so aber heute
live gibt ihn wirklich also wir haben in
einem schwarzen schuhe wirklich sehr
sehr leicht erinnert mich ein bisschen
an den micro schwanz von früher die
waren ja mal mega hype ist stellt sich
noch die frage passt im jahr
ich habe ihn in schuhgröße 43 bestellt
und so sieht's aus ja gern auch noch den
anderen schweiz vergleich wirklich also
hier bin ich wirklich stolz auf mich
selber habe ich einen deutlichen
schnapper gemacht kosten jetzt gerade
auch noch 30 euro oder so aber lohnt
sich auf jeden fall das wäre jetzt so
das erste produkt wo ich sagen würde 11
5 sterne auf jeden fall gerechtfertigt
sollten aber gar nicht viel zeit
verliert machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt mal schauen was hier gutes drin
ist das geil
also also wenn ich jetzt einen kleinen
cousin hätte oder so dann kleinen sohn
den ich noch nicht habe dann würde ich
immer auf jeden fall so was als wecker
direkt kaufen ja ich hab das ding jetzt
als so klein erwartet ja das hat auch 30
euro gekostet
aber wenn jetzt auch ältere leute
zuschauen die ein kind haben kommentiert
gerne mal wie geil ist das sowas als
wecker habe ich noch nicht gesehen
deswegen
[Applaus]
das ding haben sogar auch gerade stehen
und sitzen
das noch mal und jetzt kann man hier
hinten ganz einfach einstellen also ich
habe jetzt gerade mal hier den alarm
eingestellt der müsste in einer minute
losgehen bin ich gespannt was das teil
dann mach ich schreibe auch gern bei
eurem favorit und diesen ganzen fünf
sterne sachen in die kommentare wirklich
wahr interessieren ist auch dieses teil
oder eher der schule mal da kann man
sogar drauf drücken der leuchtet kümmert
er leuchtet jetzt vielleicht ist nämlich
los bin jetzt echt mal gespannt auf den
sound kommt okay es gibt ja alles klar
also geiles ding gefällt mir ich fragte
mich jetzt gerade ob wir noch mehr
sachen haben hier in diesem paket
sollten einige süßigkeiten drin sein
zum beispiel diese hummer nudeln ist
aber gar nicht für das jetzige video ein
paket haben wir noch das größte update
sogar zwei nein das war nur ein riesiger
adventskalender
hier ist wahrscheinlich die lampen
wo ist meine lampe hätte ich glaube ich
muss jetzt leider sagen die lampe ist
noch nicht da diese einfach nicht da ich
habe gedacht dass wir alles da
vielleicht dämlich also noch extra auf
ansonsten würde ich sagen es geht leute
ich hab leider dieses insekten den ganz
vergessen denn snappy insekten fänger
deswegen ganz schön noch im nachhinein
also der bund ja wirklich sehr sehr gut
bewertet dann hat man ich frage mich
gerade ob das wirklich funktioniert wenn
man so auf sondern sec brauch geht
sondern so und dann kann ich natürlich
wieder freilassen das finde ich gut ich
würde sagen wir gehen mal auf
insektenjagd vielleicht habe schon eine
pflege in mein zimmer
ich kann mir nun wirklich serie
vorstellen ich habe wirklich immer ne
fliege im zimmer und jetzt wo ich meine
brauche habe ich keine stellung zum
pfleger sechseinhalb stunden später
leute es gibt keine fliegen das war der
erste part von amazon produkten mit fünf
sternen wie machst du das ultra spaß
wenn ihr sagt hey wir haben da auch noch
ein partner und schreibt es gerne in die
kommentare und dustin dicken daumen nach
oben da für mehr shopping videos gerne
schreibt ihr eure ideen was ich machen
soll und in die kommentare
ich bin wirklich auch für vieles und bin
einfach auch mal auf eure wünsche
gespannt wir sind uns dann morgen schon
wieder dann gibt es neues video und auf
jeden fall auch weil das mit den
adventskalendern das wird auch fresh
alle produkte sind in der video
bestellung verlinkt hagen abonnieren
nicht vergessen und ja wir sehen uns ja